est-ce que vrai ou faux Mariah Carey
veut qu'un assistant soit toujours
disponible pour qu'elle puisse se
cracher son chewing-gum dans la main
pareil
[Rires]
mais moi je
suis même c'est juste cracher non mais
ça oui
Jean-Pierre François
vrai ou faux le nouveau roi Charles III
exige que sa lunette de WC le suive
partout où il va oui c'est vrai genre
il a une station-service il est pas bien
le gars va lui mettre la lunette il ne
suit en permanence avec la lunette
parce que c'est tellement plein de
microbes moi si j'étais
sûr ça c'est le vrai luxe je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
mais avec une cuvette vrai ou faux un
célèbre animateur exige d'avoir un
terrain de paddle dans ses WC
je la présente dans sa chambre d'hôtel
d'un mannequin en plastique de genre
féminin avec les poils pubiens roses
je veux pas savoir
mais c'est vrai
ou faux après chaque prime de Secret
Story Benjamin Castaldi souhaitait
rentrer chez lui exclusivement en
hélicoptère
bien sûr c'était une fois par semaine
je vous raconte l'histoire ou pas oui à
l'époque à l'époque j'étais je divorcé
comme toujours et
[Applaudissements]
divorce toutes les deux semaines donc
forcément pendant 40 ans de ta vie tu as
divorcé donc je voulais juste rentrer
une fois par semaine à la campagne pour
vous pouvoir coucher mon petit et la
seule façon de le faire c'est d'être
pendant l'hélicoptère à après l'émission
donc du jeudi je crois et donc je vais
mais j'en prie à moitié il payait la
moitié ça coûte combien cette connerie
ça devait être 4000 euros de l'heure un
truc comme ça il y avait combien
d'heures une heure et demie 1h30 donc
cette affaire à peu près et le pilote
non mais chez moi parce que je repartais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en ai pas eu vu de la de je sors et
toi Benham parce que toi tu étais une
star mais toujours jamais tu as jamais
fait un truc de fou non j'étais vraiment
franchement moi ce qui m'intéressais
c'était rentré à la maison
[Rires]
moi je suis pas du tout là-dedans
Raymond qui me connaît extrêmement bien
moi je suis dans le je suis dans le
sport dans le vif dans la rigolade moi
c'était une un [ __ ] moi tu me donnes
un diabolofrais je suis comme un fou moi
Raymond dis-leur que les toilettes aller
dans les toilettes des palaces
qui vous suit partout comme tu sais que
tu dois donner à manger à la chambre de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vrai ou faux à chaque rendez-vous au
restaurant Anne Hidalgo demande à ce que
le chef cuistot soit remplacé par un
chef de chantier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en vélo ce weekend c'était Paris sans
voiture et bah franchement tu vois quand
tu es en vélo et que
quand tu es en vélo ouais mais alors
j'ai pas compris ce pari sans voiture je
veux dire à Hidalgo il y avait que moi
qui était comme un con avec un vélo il y
avait des voitures de partout
alors tu te retrouves comme un con à
vélo c'est encore plus de chance de te
faire écraser parce qu'en fait tout le
monde se dit bah il y a pas de voiture
donc en fait voilà j'étais avec les
enfants mon fils a gueulé ma gueuler oh
je te jure non mais c'est vrai c'est
horrible horrible et saturé et ça pollue
de fou mais je sais pas le droit de
rentrer dans Paris
c'est vrai qu'anidalgo
Paris respire mais les Parisiens ne
respire plus ça c'est sûr que et tiens
vrai ou faux après sa rupture avec
Justin Bieber Selena Gomez a demandé à
tous les Justin de son staff de changer
de prénom
même ils ont même plus le droit de
manger du Justin Bridou
les amis en train de pécondu saucisson
et c'est fou c'est normal bien ouais
c'est vrai vous auriez pu le faire
mon qui s'appelle Siri à la base je ne
veux plus de Daniel dans l'émission
je le lis franchement on en a mais c'est
vrai non non mais c'est fou c'est fou